j'accueille maintenant alexandra lamy et
jean dujardin
c'est un triomphe enfin c'est incroyable
alors vous êtes pour ceux qui ne savent
pas encore vous êtes les héros de un
gars une fille qui prend un petit
programme de sept minutes diffusé depuis
deux ans sur france 2 avant le 20h
et c'est vrai que les présentateurs du
journal télévisé valls sur france 2 mais
vous vous êtes toujours là chaque soir 5
millions de téléspectateurs suivent les
aventures de chouchou et loulou un jeune
couple que vous incarnez qu'ils sont
ensemble depuis sept ans lui c'est vous
ouais vous êtes plutôt machos casanier
dragueur jaloux tendance infidèle
colérique fans de foot et de bagnols 1
c'est vous vous êtes coquine coquette
pipelette accro au shopping et au sexe
oui jalouse mais tendance fidèles vous
voilà oui alors le programme dont le
connaît c'est une succession de petites
saynètes entrecoupées d'un habillage
très chouette très très branché 1
la série est issu d'un concept québécois
mais elle explose dans tous les pays
d'europe où elle est adaptée
alors évidemment pour ceux qui
connaissent pas on va regarder à quoi ça
ressemble mal et lozère signifions quoi
tu me pourrir son contrat
le débat s'ouvrait la famille les filles
c'est qu'il y aura les campings non je
trouve pas les vacances
un gars une fille
soir si on prend
fusion
parce que c'est alors avec se tenait à
alès oui vous rêviez temps petit de
devenir gardienne de chèvres c'est vrai
oui c'est ma comme vous savez ça oui
c'est vrai et puis ensuite formation de
théâtre classique au conservatoire de
nîmes et en 92 vous débarquez à paris
pour des auditions vous commencé le
théâtre les téléfilms vous êtes évincée
du casting d'un gars une fille départ à
cause d'un mauvais partenaire pour
redemander une chance et cette fois
c'est jean il a dit à la productrice
c'est une nana qui pourrait me faire
donc ça c'était décision
j'entends
ouais il a dit qu'ils allaient le camus
saint paul à prendre parce qu elle
vraiment j'ai envie de me l'a tapée quoi
c'est le chaînon janvier à rueil
malmaison
après le bac et le service militaire
deux ans serrurier dans le bâtiment
ouais ça apprend la vie ça non ouais
ouais
j'essaie dé comics en bâtiment c'est un
comique en matière et le soir one man
show dans des cafés théâtres et puis
membre de la bande du carré blanc est là
un jour
jean dujardin déniché par stéphane
calvet le directeur artistique de
l'émission vous faites graines de stars
way et vous gagner trois fois de suite
ouais c'est vrai celle record chaque
fois que j'arrivais plus jamais ça et
vous vous y retournez quand même ouais
c'est vrai c'est super souvenir quoi
c'était c'était fabuleux
super pétoche mais bien content mais
c'est là on s'est rencontré d'ailleurs
ben voilà et on va voir avec quoi vous
avez gagné
allez salut salut
sa femme sa forte ça farte bombe à
welcome sur la plage de lacanau beach je
me présente je m'appelle brice vient de
nice de nice tu sais comment elle
m'appelle de famille six mois le sniper
suis harcelé la journée je me casse la
baraque à frites obligé de surf et la
nuit à la bougie
mais la nuit c'est les sirènes qui me
gonfle non attendez attendez je veux
dire c'est dur d'être un canon je le
souhaite à personne
en plus moi le style blondasse plastique
féline et je vais te dire ça me laisse
rêveur
f d'ailleurs si anne pitchouns dans le
groupe un peu raboteuse qui aiment le
gall ac
rendez vous ce soir en camping des
vaniteux emplacement de l demande brice
le roi de la glisse alors là vous
décidez avec avec vos copains de
l'époque la bande du carré blanc de
créer une troupe de faire les lignes
c'est nouveau et qui fait ça
oh
c
[Musique]
non
essai
les nous c nous beaucoup d'émissions de
télévision des parodies sur france2
d'ailleurs souvent est alors en 99
isabelle camus la productrice et le
pense d'abord à josé garcia pour un gars
une fille puis voilà il était pris par
le cinéma et c'est lui qui a suggéré
votre nom ah bon ouais c'est ça c'est
vrai mais c'est bien sûr c'est vrai que
j'y allais à reculons départ
ouais parce que je suis en train de
repeindre la chambre de mon fils et puis
moi les castings c'est pas ils sont pas
super bien quoi donc
elle m'a appelée puis elle m'a montré
les les vidéos des canadiens donc et
puis ça m'a plu
vous avez vu cinq filles et puis la 6e
c'était alex ouais ouais ouais ouais
puis c'est passé tout de suite enfants
nous ont vite délivré même débit un
grande complicité tout de suite voilà un
film en fait ce qu'il dit en parlant de
vous et c'est mon pote avec des seins en
attendant même temps c'est sympa et pas
ça voilà justement alors j'ai des
problèmes avec vos conjoints respectifs
il paraît qu il vous embrasse plus
souvent que votre jules c'est pas vrai
bon c'est thierry ardisson évidemment
d'organiser un dîner
1 c'est vrai oui on s'est rencontré un
dîner avec ses deux coups pour être sûr
qu il y avait passé des trucs à 4 quoi
c'est rigolo
cette année ou après après quoi vider
tous les cas nous a rejoints
je suis tout seul
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu